Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, I'm Jan, and
in this video we're diving deep into that
shock twist Season 4 finale, what it means for
Season 5, plus all the clues, call-backs and
easter eggs that predicted the big ending.
Spoilers ahead, of course, so take care.
Season 4 ends on a bombshell,
with Silver's dirty tricks paying
off as Cobra Kai win the Tournament.
But Kreese's victory is short-lived as
Silver has him arrested after getting Stingray to
frame Kreese for assault by preying on Raymond's
weakness to be part of Cobra Kai.
And Silver plans to take over the
dojo franchise all for himself now
he's got rid of his own weakness...
I'm shedding my weakness.
Captain.
Although Silver's betrayal
comes as a shock to Kreese...
There is no one in the world
I trust more than you.
...it was hinted at back in the opening episode:
Turns out, you disappearing was the best thing
that ever happened to me.
As the head of Cobra Kai and
a former army Captain, Kreese is used to
being the one in control, giving orders,
and he regards Silver as his weak underling.
Do you remember the cage?
We both thought we were gonna die.
I wasn't afraid.
You were.
If it wasn't for me,
you'd still be back in that pit.
But Silver used Kreese's
attitude against him this season:
What your opponent is thinking is key.
If they think you're weak, that's when
you can surprise them with your strength.
Although previously Silver has happily repaid
Kreese's life-saving in Vietnam over the years...
Anything you need...
I'm there for you.
...after so many decades he's grown sick of
Kreese continually throwing it in his face.
How many times do you expect me to
repay that debt before we're square?
As Kreese himself said this season, 'To be a
Cobra Kai, you have to have a killer instinct.'
And that's exactly what Silver has in the end.
Another hint to Silver's behind-the-scenes
machinations against his old army pal came when
we saw him reading Leviathan by Thomas Hobbes
who argued a strong ruler or government
with absolute powers was necessary to
live in peace and avoid war and social conflict.
The book was written during the English Civil War
and the constant fighting between Cobra Kai, Eagle
Fang, and Miyagi-do could be seen as an analogy.
And with Silver now taking over Cobra
Kai and disbanding the competition,
he might well see himself as bringing peace and
stability to the karate world in the valley.
It's most unlikely though that Silver's
seen the last of Kreese as he won't go
down without fighting back, as
he said in the first episode:
People expect men of our age to pack
it in and go off into the sunset.
But I still have some fight left in me.
Indeed, Silver would do well to remember
what happened to their first Captain
in Vietnam when he took on Kreese.
That was a seminal moment for Kreese becoming
the man we know today as even when the
possibility arose for both men to make it out
of their battle alive, Kreese chose no mercy.
In Season 4 though we've seen a few
cracks in Kreese's "no mercy" mantra.
For instance, he told Silver to go easy
on Johnny after he confronted him;
and encouraged Tory to play
it fair in the tournament,
in contrast to how he urged his students to
use dirty tactics in the original Karate Kid.
I'm surprised you backed off
on Nichols in the finals.
That's not like you.
Well, what can I say?
I had a moment of sympathy.
It seems Kreese is getting a sense
of how wrong his extreme methods have been and
it's a hint he could follow a redemption path
of sorts in the future, especially if he finds
that Johnny repays that small act of kindness
by helping Kreese get out of his predicament.
And we'll see whether Stingray ends up retracting
his accusation against Kreese or if he simply
becomes Silver's yes-man and punching bag at Cobra
Kai given his desperate desire to belong.
Although Silver seems on top of the karate world
by the end, he'll likely have to reckon
with some fallout from Tory in Season 5.
Because although he claims he's changed
since the wild events of Karate Kid 3...
I'm not that man anymore.
...in reality, he's just got more devious.
So, instead of using his vast fortune to
acquire a killer karate kid of his own...
You just bought yourself a champion.
...now, he takes a more direct route
with his money, bribing the tournament
referee to ensure a Cobra Kai win.
Silver's cheating not only robs the other
dojos of a fair chance at the title,
it also robs Tory of the sense of accomplishment
and validation she's so desperate for.
If I could win this one time, then I could look at
that trophy and know I was best at something.
So, how will she handle the situation now
she knows she didn't win fair and square?
Will she keep quiet?
Or stand up to Silver, especially
if she discovers his part in Kreese's downfall?
To answer that, let's go back to her final fight.
Remember after she accidentally elbowed Sam in the
eye that Silver insisted she do the same again,
but deliberately this time...
She can't see, she can't fight.
...which, by the way, was one of his rules
when he trained Daniel in the third movie
and part of the pain-provoking strategy he got
Mike Barnes to employ in the final tournament:
Well, Tory was having none
of that in her finals.
Give her a shot to the other eye.
Won't I get disqualified?
I don't need to cheat to win.
A moment which takes me back to the original
movie and Bobby's fight against Daniel:
I want him out of commission.
But I'll be disqualified!
Except in Tory's case, she sticks to her guns and
Kreese actually backs his student this time...
Let her do what she wants.
This is your fight now.
So, whatever happens, it's up to you.
...because Johnny reminded Kreese what he
put him through back in the day:
You forced me to fight dirty.
Sweep the leg.
You sacrificed my
soul so Cobra Kai could stay number one.
So, perhaps now Tory knows the referee
was paid off, Silver may well end up
regretting the advice he gave the Cobra
Kai students earlier this season:
Take all that anger and store it.
You're gonna need it when the time comes.
Robby may also prove a problem for Silver in
Season 5, especially after Robby gets a wake-up
call that he's not been the kind of mentor he
hoped to be when he finds new kid Kenny punching
former bully Anthony in the locker room.
This is not how I trained you.
It's Cobra Kai.
No mercy.
Intentionally or not, that
Cobra Kai 'no mercy' mantra is what Robby rammed
home to Kenny during their tournament fight.
And because Robby put passion in front
of principle, he ended up proving
true the Miyagism that...
Even if you win, you lose.
Johnny warned his son about his
old sensei earlier this season:
Kreese is brainwashing you,
like he brainwashed me.
And Daniel also drew on his own Karate Kid
3 experience to warn Robby about Silver:
One day you'll find yourself with some kid's
blood all over your shirt and you'll hope it's
not too late to change course.
But Robby believed he wasn't
like his dad or Daniel;
he was in control of the situation,
using Cobra Kai to get what he wanted, taking
their best and mixing it with Miyagi-do.
In the end though, Kreese's insistence
that nothing matters but winning...
It's about being a champion.
That reputation will follow you
the rest of your life
... still managed to
pollute Robby's mind-set...
I'll use whatever it takes to win.
The upshot of it all is that, instead of forging
his own path, as he believed he was, Robby has
actually been perpetuating the damaging merciless
cycle kicked off in the 1980s by Kreese, who
learned it from his Captain in Vietnam then passed
it on to Silver, Johnny, Robby, and now to Kenny.
So, in the end, Robby has taken a similar
road filled with obsession and hatred as
both his sensei and his dad once took:
I had all this hate inside of me.
And I thought I could use
Cobra Kai to control that.
But it just made things worse.
However, Robby's recognition of what he's done
is a step towards changing things, and it also
opens the way to reconciliation with his father.
I'm sick of blaming you, Dad.
It'll be alright.
And there's more hope ahead for this next
generation of karate kids as Daniel and
Johnny also eventually recognise that the way
they've been acting was more about protecting
themselves and proving a point than looking
out for the best interests of their students:
You and I may be set in our
ways, but these kids...
They can learn from both of us and use what
we teach them to create their own way.
Too often all the senseis have used their students
to prove themselves right and feed their own egos,
teaching them the brief sugar-rush of
self-esteem that comes with winning,
instead of teaching them true resilience and
self-compassion which is gracious in victory and
sees set-backs as a chance to learn.
You kicked ass today.
Could've gone either way.
Don't let it eat you up.
Trust me.
Although Johnny may
have begun to repair the relationship with his son
Robby in the finale, his role as a father figure
to Miguel is on the rocks and Miguel decides
to leave home and find his biological father.
I looked him up.
It says he lives in Mexico now.
Johnny and Miguel's relationship comes under
strain when Miguel trains at Miyagi-do and gets
closer to Daniel who also becomes a father-figure
for a while, teaching him about fixing cars and
opening up a different worldview.
Johnny's attempts to reconnect go
horribly wrong when he confesses he wants to
be a good father to Miguel while drunk...
I love you.
I love you too, Robby.
Their faltering relationship comes to a head
just before his tournament fight with Hawk:
Whose side are you on?
What do you mean?
I'm on your side, Diaz.
Always.
That, combined with his catastrophic fall and
injury, makes Miguel reconsider everything.
And Johnny's words...
Show me you're ready to be a man.
... appear to be the final straw.
In the letter he leaves, he says karate
isn't enough anymore and he needs to know
where he came from to understand himself.
Johnny tells Carmen he'll bring Miguel home
and given that Tanner Bucannan has been involved
in Season 5 filming in Puerto Rico, presumably
standing in for scenes set in Mexico, it looks
like Robby will also be going along for the trip.
Although Miguel knows his father has
been involved in illegal activities,
what his mother never told him was that his
father doesn't actually know Miguel even exists,
so he could end up in a lot of trouble when he
presumably manages to track his dad down.
Mid-way through the season, the
show already starts teeing up
more of the original cast from the Karate Kid
movies to make a splashy return in Season 5:
Are any other Cobra Kais from your past are gonna
come out of the woodwork and destroy our lives?
No.
Well, I can't say that for sure.
And I'd lay money on a comeback from 'tournament
terror' Mike Barnes, the karate bad boy who Silver
employed to wreak revenge on Daniel and Mr
Miyagi after Kreese went out of business.
Barnes has already popped up in previous
seasons via photos and film footage.
And this season, Daniel drops his name
when he tells Johnny about their fight:
After I beat Barnes, I never saw Silver again.
But what seals the deal in my mind for Barnes's
return is what Silver says to Kreese as his former
Captain's hauled off by the police in the finale.
I'm sure I can dig up a friend
or two to help out with Cobra
Kai while you deal with your legal problems.
Actor Sean Kanan, who played Barnes in the 80s,
has said we 'probably haven't seen the
last of Mike', that he's certainly open
to returning and is a fan of the new show.
And when asked if Barnes might have become
a better person, he said he hoped
so as he thought Barnes had got
'a bunch of bad wiring and messages'
as a kid but was young enough then that
'with the right kind of mentorship
he could [have turned] it around'.
Given his negotiating skills in the movie,
maybe Barnes would be keen to try and get a
stake in Silver's new Cobra Kai franchise.
Do you fight as hard as you negotiate?
Harder.
You got your 50%.
Whatever Barnes's role in the show ends up being,
Kanan has said he'd like to bring 'a lot more
colours [...] to the character' as he thought
he was 'pretty one-dimensional' back then.
Along with Barnes, I wonder if we could also
see some of Silver's henchmen back again:
that's Snake, who was played by Jonathan Avildsen,
son of the director of the original trilogy,
and Dennis, played by skilled martial artist
and actor, William Christopher Ford.
Another blast from the past who we know will
certainly be back for Season 5 is Chozen.
After appearing in Season 3 during Daniel's trip
to Okinawa, Chozen is now State-side and is all
ready to team up with his former rival to take
down Cobra Kai, as Daniel implies he won't be
honouring his Season 3 agreement with Kreese for
the tournament losers to close down their dojo.
There's too much at stake to honor an
agreement made with men who have none.
Will you help me finally put an end to Cobra Kai?
This is the second time Chozen has proved
crucial in a Cobra Kai finale.
At the end of Season 3, the Secret
Miyagi pressure points he previously taught Daniel
saved his ex-enemy during his fight with Kreese.
If an enemy insists on war...
then you take away their ability to wage it.
And now, after mending bridges last season...
If it means anything Chozen, I forgive you.
It means a great deal.
...Chozen and Daniel are
joining forces, at Mr Miyagi's graveside,
complete with one of his beloved bonsai trees.
Given that after the events of Karate Kid 2,
Chozen became part of the Miyagi-do family
in Okinawa and has been for many years, it seems
likely there will be less friction between these
two new allies than there was between Daniel
and Johnny when they tried to work together.
And I'm curious whether he'll reveal any
more new Miyagi techniques next season.
Season 4 is also loaded with even more easter
eggs, hidden references, and call-backs to the
original Karate Kid movies, which I go into
in more detail in my Things You Missed video.
I'll add the link here and in the video
description as soon as it's ready.
So, what did you think of the latest season?
And what would you like to happen in season 5?
And if you enjoyed this, don't forget to
leave a thumbs-up, it's hugely appreciated.
Tap left to discover all the easter eggs and
details you may have missed in Season 4.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!